aimes Mayfield is 11 years old he was a
Cub Scout in Colorado he was told to
research and ask a question that impacts
his community during a Q&A with state
senator Vicki Marble who's a Republican
and his question was a very good
question he said - Vicki marble an issue
that I'm concerned about is common-sense
gun control I was shocked that you
co-sponsored a bill to allow domestic
violence offenders to continue owning a
gun why on earth would you want somebody
who beats their wife to have access to a
gun good question good question from an
eleven-year-old but the question was
considered disrespectful by the leaders
of Ames Cub Scout den they're called
dens and he's no longer going to be
allowed to participate in that
particular Cub Scout group they he said
given that the Las Vegas shooting
happened I felt that it would be a
reasonable thing to ask couldn't agree
more
Ames and Gabby Giffords former
Congresswoman Gabby Giffords is
supporting aims she tweeted to him a few
days ago this is exactly the kind of
courage we need in Congress Eames call
me in 14 years I'll campaign for you and
Giffords husband astronaut Mark Kelly
called Ames and his mom Lori Mayfield to
have a private conversation about the
situation also very supportive so what's
the bad news the bad news is that his
Cub Scout den is no longer welcoming him
the bad news is that this was considered
a disrespectful question when really
it's the exact type of question that
should be encouraged the good news is
that another Cub Scout den has invited
him to join and he would be
transitioning to the Boy Scouts anyway
in February so listen I've made no
secret of the fact that I don't like the
Boy Scouts as an organization they've
made some improvements to policy over
the years I would never have my kid
participate it's also mostly a religious
organization there are some non
religious individual Boy Scout troops
but overall this is a religious
organization and if I had a kid and to
quote former producer Lewis if it was an
accidental kid that I had I'd probably
love the kid and everything would be
great no matter what I don't want my kid
involved with the Boy Scouts of America
and and it's good that another den is
going to have aims now there is one
other piece of controversy here which is
that there are some reports which say it
wasn't his question about gun control
that got him kicked out
it was his question about chicken gate
chicken gate what am I talking about
chicken gate is a scandal involving the
Republican state senator in question
Vicki marble where she said she made
comments I mean it's so crazy in 2013
where she said when you look at life
expectancy there are problems in the
black race sickle cell anemia is
something that comes up diabetes is
something that's prevalent in the
genetic makeup and you just can't help
it although I've got to say I've had
I've never had better barbecue and
better chicken and ate better in my life
than when you go down south and I love
it everybody loves it so that was a
that's chicken gate for make Vicki
marble and there's some controversy as
to whether Ames is in trouble the
11-year old for asking about gun control
or for asking about chicken gate what's
interesting is that sinclair owned news
affiliates that are reporting on this
are saying the reason he was kicked out
was the gun control question whereas non
sinclair reports seemed to say that it
was the chicken gate question kind of
weird but what i want to say is good job
aims keep it up
your question was great gabby giffords
is right astronaut Mark Kelly is right
don't let Vicki marble or your Cub Scout
den dissuade you from asking those
questions